foreign  [Music]  I've been looking forward to this moment  ever since baby Tommy was cut out of my  abdomen cheers everybody  [Music]  it's time  where is the pattern of the pride  Robert Robert they're calling you thanks  a lot Carol  here's the plan we're gonna head to the  next Island for help on my counts ten  nine why are you counting from ten but  is this a rocket launch you can find on  four this weekend hasn't exactly got a  plan Pirates chasing he wasn't on your  vision board you're the only thing on my  mission is that blood  [Music]  okay yeah just you know I looked over  there and I saw the blood and you know I  think I saw some brain was that brain  stuff well you know what maybe we should  let's just step away  [Music]